jambes redescend donc gelé par hectare
dans my fair lady mary hopper incarne le
personnage principal d'eliza doolittle
cette jeune fille des bas quartiers dans
le londres des années 1930 qui devient
grâce à un professeur de phonétique une
femme de la haute société
[Musique]
dès qu'elle a su qu'elle incarnerait le
rôle emblématique
la jeune comédienne et chanteuse a tout
de suite adhéré à l'esprit de la
fabrique opéra un esprit de famille
c'est vraiment une expérience incroyable
je suis tellement ravie de d'avoir pu
participer à ce projet qui est tellement
intéressant
artistiquement mais aussi humainement
parce que ce but de démocratiser l'opéra
à la comédie musicale
ça me touche particulièrement voilà de
faire partager ça à des gens qui
n'auraient pas forcément l'occasion de
connaître ses oeuvres surtout en france
qui sont des oeuvres pas tellement au
connu je transformerai cette petite
sauvage en princesse chris bell id campe
le rôle du professeur higgins le
professeur de phonétique misogyne
pygmalion d'eliza doolittle chanteur
d'opéra professionnels c'est la première
fois qu'il a un rôle principal dans une
comédie musicale
que fait des coeurs en comédie musicale
avant et et des premiers rôles deuxième
rôle j'en ai fait dans l'opéra mais
jamais comme là et c'est tellement
passionnant parce que tu n'as pas que
juste quand et chanteurs d'opéra tut tut
est coincé par la formalité de la voix
ça pose des demandes à ton corps
physiquement tandis que là tu es
vraiment comédien c'est la pièce d'abord
apprenti choristes techniciens
professionnels à la fabrique opéra
tout le monde est mis sur un même pied
d'égalité jean claude cotillard metteur
en scène de carmen et de la flûte
enchantée fait même une furtive
apparition
l'esprit de famille est bien là et le
public ne s'y trompe pas surprise en
fait une raison
chaque main je pensais que c'était voilà
franchement c'est super c'est magnifique
vraiment on s'est régalé a trouvé ça
très professionnel et puis chaleureux je
dire qu'à une ambiance de camaraderie de
voix que c'est une équipe quoi
quand l'équipe
tout est bien qui finit bien donc
la fabrique opéra devrait encore nous
étonner
l'année prochaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]